c'est un grand un grand plaisir d'un
toner quand on vous en hommage aux mages
à votre travail parce que bon j'ai c'est
sûr que j'ai j'ai eu dans ma carrière
pas mal de dommages mais à des hommages
qui sont beaucoup plus chers à mon coeur
que d'autres et cet hommage du caribéen
films internationaux festive film
festival ici à los angeles bon mais ça
fait partie de ces images qui me sont
très chers que j'apprécie parce que
s'ils se sentir honoré par le sien puis
je sais la caraïbe c'est aux états unis
et nous pour les artistes que nous
sommes si c'est très important d'être
reconnu par les siens
même si on reçoit dix mille pris
ailleurs même si mais de ne pas recevoir
des prix ne pas recevoir des zones où de
son propre pays
c'est vrai que c'est pas ça fait mal
quoi et on en attend ça on attend que ça
arrive et quand ça arrive on est très
content puisqu'on sait que c'est tout un
pays si votre pays qui voient connaît le
travail que vous avez fait et aussi
l'hommage que vous lui faites en créant
et ce travail étant honoré on ou non en
même temps votre pays